[Music]
Charlie Sheen had that epic meltdown and
where he was sort of the only thing
anybody talked about in the world and
then you were one of the first people to
make a movie with Charlie Sheen to start
a project with him right after that and
I'm curious what was it like being
around that guy when he was in that
state I've I've seen him since and he's
sort of calmed down but you were in the
eye of the hurricane
during that Charlie Sheen mania what was
that like gosh uh you know I don't think
that it I let's just say I love this guy
a lot he's amazing
that whatever was happening that's his
own thing but I will say that I love him
and I love the way he thinks I love his
mind I love the way he speaks he speaks
in ways that are sort of poetic and
strange and beautiful that I don't fully
understand literally but I understand on
a deeper level in my body like he'll say
something like um like Oh like one time
you said hey what's your favorite drink
and I said gin and he said oh man Dan
Jun that's intense last time I drank gin
I did a backflip off my bed into Mexico
and I was like yeah yeah yeah I went a
long way there but I did get it on some
level which I'm thinking he's basically
saying it's intense the strength but I
don't know how you can literally do a
backflip off your bed New Mexico unless
Charlie has done it I'm telling you he
think he's done yeah I mean he told me
he did it but that's the kind of guy is
and I love him and it's uh yeah I was
happy to here's what's interesting to me
you've always seemed I've known you for
a long time you're very sweet guy but
you seem kind of mild-mannered and you
seem like a contrast a real contrast
with Charlie Sheen especially Charlie
Sheen at the height of his partying ways
yes would you have gone on an adventure
with him if you'd had the chance
well I uh yeah well I did have a chance
um and looking back maybe I should have
done it whatever he uh he uh he actually
invited me he said to me hey man what
are you doing this weekend now where are
you he just calls you up in the middle
the night was he I know it was he in
your medicine cabinet when you opened it
up
oh yeah in your glove compartment hey
man I was like ah no I was we were
working we were on set and they say hey
what are you doing this weekend and I
said I don't know and he said a bunch of
us are going down to Colombia I got a
private plane and we're gonna go on a
little trip down there little venture
you want to go and I love him I want to
seem cool tough with him
and I was like yeah maybe let me think
about that really what I was thinking
was I gotta go home and I gotta clear
this with my wife and see but this is
what this could be so I go home I say
hey sweetie how are you um hey funny
thing happened today you know Charlie
Chi we have plans this weekend because
uh Charlie Sheen asked if I would go
with him to Colombia on a private plane
should I go and she said um you've gotta
be kidding me yeah and she said uh-uh
you are a father now uh-huh you have to
be responsible
you could die down there yeah and uh uh
true and I called him and I said I
couldn't go cuz uh I was probably gonna
be sick this weekend that's right :
here's the thing looking back on it do
you think you should have gone uh see
that's the thing as part of me would
think like I've got to go to just see
what happens first when he says a bunch
of us my mind goes to who else is on
that plane yeah yeah they wearing
clothes what are they doing well I yes I
wanted to go I mean yeah I am what
you're saying is how I live my life
which is a constant state of I want to
be doing it I want to be in it at the
same time I want to be at home yeah and
and that's know you're talking I'm
saying and so you're talking about I
don't and so I and I don't have like a
ton of adventures like that looking back
on my life I won't have a lot of
adventures like that the same time maybe
I'll you know I'll be old and alive at
that point before I die later so you
know maybe I've made it pretty far
because I didn't have what a sweet
perspective you had a guy in the
audience named Trevor and I are gonna
get a plane and we're gonna go on some
crazy adventure where you gonna go well
we don't know yet we haven't worked it
out
you're coming with us and it's gonna get
crazy well I I will go with you as long
as my wife says we're gonna bring
protein shakes and a lot of Emily
Dickens problems